ciao ciao ospite è costato 100 della
spesa e ho assistito a un gioco che
facevano padre il figlio che allora
avanti tutto il supermercato stazione
grande guarda il video
in realtà bellissimo chiama servizi spa
rf di schizzi questo bambino che
seguendo alternativa ai vaccini esigendo
poca fatica sai qualsiasi malattia ma
cioè se registi a questa roba a
resistere a qualsiasi altra ciao ragazzi
ben tornati alla nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
che ho appena visto
per un tema così in particolare ha
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia una persona per me
molto speciale che di base è riuscita a
resistere ai conati che la visione
diciamo che che il vedermi ogni mattina
a scuola alzato in casa che per anni è
riuscita a sopportare la visione della
mia com'è che si dice in italiano una
persona che per quattro anni 55 anni ha
sopportato il giovedì santo è anche il
modo in cui mi vestivo al liceo sto
parlando di una mia amica storica peg a
salve
ci ho messo un po presenta la tranquilla
eravamo a cena con degli amici in un tot
di fronte c'era una coppia di fidanzati
lui dà un morso al suo bel panino e si
sporca a di vaio divisa sull'albero chi
lo guarda con la chance e ripulisce la
vogliono inizia così il dito e synth
scandalo degli occhi poi sinde candito
spesso non era proprio
io ne avrei coperti poi del mio gomito
ed è l'inizio di un ora per che schifo
la maionese e uno di quei cibi che
buonissimo insieme ma viene preso dalla
bocca degli anni si è diciamo in altre
parole si piccolo molto stretto c'era
una signora sulla cinquantina nel
momento in cui ne siamo passati a fianco
si è calato i leggins fino sopra le
ginocchia ed enti
erano entrante io una cosa del centro
non l'ho mai visto il video mio in tutto
ciò a mia madre sia messa a urlare
insultando la caduta stare io ho cercato
ma si può fare pipì in piedi alla
fermata dell'autobus video la signora
che si tirò giù le braghe e cominciò
davanti a tutti questo è un problema non
è meglio non aveva tutti cerco anche di
nascondersi dietro un cespuglio solo che
dall'altro lato c'erano tutti che la
storia
guardando però quando ti scappa che non
è mai capitato io pure l'autobus di
rosso e devo fare una premessa io ho un
gatto che adora annusare la gente ha
sempre la gente chiama ma una sera e
intanto il gatto che annusa vale però io
me ne vado
e quando torno vedo mia mamma impieghi
che sto tenendo fermo il gatto e le sta
annusando tic e le diceva nel frattempo
così impari così sai che dà fastidio e
intanto ne annusato anni
adesso so che il mio gatto avesse appena
domino per ogni città o arrivato mia
madre con la faccia nel ben canto morte
buona giornata c'è un ospite ma firma di
dare 39 come se il gatto per aver omesso
e quello che tiro di piatto sarà stato
il ritmo ma finalmente ha capito cosa
deve fare
praticamente era in piazza duomo
contratto un piccione è andato a
schiantarsi contro un palo non certo
punto un ragazzo ha raccolto il piccione
da terra si è messo dell'acqua in bocca
e si è messo il becco del filone imbolc
sandra dell'acqua per farlo riprendere
al che i riccionesi è ripreso dopo dieci
quindici dice ma veramente oh mio dio
però ha salvato un piccione lo so però
dai dai
io preferirei veramente anno cioè
piccioli sono bruttissimi
non è che sono brutte che c'hanno 2000
malattie tra l'altro quindi lui chissà
salvato ha dato la sua vita per il
piccione o magari il motivo per questo
messo l'acqua in bocca di sì che lo
conoscevo in pizza motivo anche numero
essendo tipo gara su john zhao un
pomeriggio a roma e ritorno dall
università arrivo nel testare della
stazione e vedo un signore che sputa
addosso ad un piccione dalle scale della
metro arriva un altro signore che inizia
a sputare sul signore che sputava sul
piccioni è stato rilanciato il mio padre
comprò ciao vorrei sottolineare che pur
di deiezioni corposi piccioni sono
fortissima no invece tu lo sai che una
volta io ho beccato in autobus uno che
buffone e sputato a hanno i mezzi volevo
raccontarvi quando in prima liceo la mia
professoressa italia non mandò in o la
professori a recuperare un libro appunto
della professoressa dimenticato appena
arrivato apro la porta e la cina che
mi ritrovo davanti e la mia
professoressa di biologia seduta sul
tavolo con il preside in mezzo alle sue
gambe
ovviamente la frase che mi è uscita è
stata anche qua appena reso già quello
del preside
diciamo che io venga abbiamo
testimoniato un sacco di cose durante
gli anni del liceo che secondo me sono
arrivate visto che è avvenuto a caracas
2 nostri amici stavano litigando f
attirato da un lato della classe
all'altro non mi ricordo cosa in faccia
api che si aggira degli a lanciando un
cestino della monnezza in mezzo c'era
una nostra amica che era seduto al banco
in prima fila l'ha preso in testa e
quindi si è trovata nel cestino
ribaltamento
mi ricordo come era come la nostra amica
prima di morire alle nostre amiche buona
salute è emigrato all'estero allora
l'anno scorso sono stato in brasile un
mese e mezzo è stata a fare volontariato
praticamente li abbia in brasile
immagino che saprai che le rapine sono
veramente all'ordine del giorno e c'è
questa ragazza che stava camminando per
strada questi si imbatta in questo
rapinatore questo incontro è stato
abbastanza violento più violento
minaccioso così ma lei non si è lasciata
spaventare dalla cosa gli ha dato i
soldi così e poi deciso anche di
iniziare una conversazione con questa
ragazza ed è finita praticamente così
presto tra i due in cui lei non so
perché affascinati stima da questo tipo
per la pilatura
arrivano assicurando quel lei morale
della favola dopo che le era stata
rapinata in maniera anche abbastanza
brusca lui l'ha invitato a mangiare e se
non abbiamo già perso due che sono di
quelli che ha un mcdonald's alla fine
della cena praticamente lui ha detto beh
adesso coi soliti rubato gli offre la
cena e le ha offerto stasera mcdonald
lei poi tornata a casa tutta contenta e
racconta storie di amici e sta passando
alcun bellissimo messaggio che se uno è
di meter ragazza accelera premier sa che
la l'altro fate anche una bellissima
figura perché lei di paghera lasciato
gamba in realtà l'inter lavoro che
proprio nella storia andava bene guarda
amore di mamma allora rapinata di un
giorno che papa ha messo un coltello
alla gola ma poi offerta la cena al mare
eravamo sul bagnasciuga cugina e c'era
un bimbo col pannolone che sta giocando
nel 18mo tutti meno due anni massimo ma
che carino questo bimbo come ti chiami
questo bimbo guarda adesso commenta
questa va benissimo rimasto in silenzio
per qualche minuto senza dirci niente
senza commentare questo fatto per un bel
po di tempo e niente questo era bambino
e roger rabbit
o magari solo me [ __ ] e book capitano
africano e poi kimi di cognome e tipo
jonico che se lo ripete poi veloce e gli
dei genitori di due le hanno voluto bene
come la famiglia chi visitava non è
tanto carriera credo una coppia di
signori anziani che
erano particolarmente strane oltre al
fatto che sembra un po sporchi questi
due da quello che ho capito erano marito
e moglie
la moglie stava seduta davanti e il
marito dietro e la moglie che sembrava
una signora abbastanza pazza e faceva
ogni due secondi il gesto di grattarsi
la testa ma si grattava forte forte
sempre più forte fino a quando a un
certo punto il marito gridando davanti a
tutti dicevano anali deve esprimere un
limone di testa tutto 100 ciliano ovvero
da mungere le monete testate tete essere
un limone tagliato metà lo spreme sulla
destra sulla destra della moglie di eros
tra fina tutto in testa e i fasci
kechiche ovvero strati nastra prina la
cosa che si strappino civici da il primo
ne il signore appunto tutto bene forse a
me mi hanno messo la benzina 1 ciao e
lavorano un negozio da sei anni c'erano
una mamma con un bambino dove lui
guardava delle cose a sinistra del
negozio alla mamma completamente a
destra sente un rumore assordante di una
scoreggia fortissima provenire da destra
vi gira verso la mamma la mamma mi
guarda con stupore e poi guarda il
figlio fa michael non si fanno queste
cose ma in realtà era stata palesemente
lei e la guardavo come per dire signora
ho capito che è stata lei e lei
continuava a sgridare il figlio che
poverino era lì in early cioè lei la
madre infama mangiato bevuto il figlio
che era tra uni per la vita amico 60 è
spostato lui però un cecchino che è
stato lì a continuare la sua
martinangelo e comunque ragazzi campioni
mondiali di dissimulare corale ha
scoraggiato è che dire ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video io
ringrazio pagan per essersi prestata
così via se ti vedo ora uscirai non
aspetterò mai più un autobus alla
fermata con lo stesso stato d'animo di
prima grazie anche voi che avete
guardato questo video e soprattutto
fatemi sapere se anche voi magari è
capitato un qualcosa di analogo o se
magari vi è successo qualcosa
se avete una vita piatta io naturalmente
come sempre vi invito a farmi sapere
quale sarebbero dei temi che mi
piacerebbero e allo stesso tempo che
invito iscrivervi a questo canale
attivare le notifiche sono volute per
adesso un video e ci vediamo la prossima
settimana con un altro vita buttata ciao
ciao bravissimi insieme